[Music]
he was
the sweetest soul he always smiled
and played and he was rambunctious and
spunky
hurt shocking
i just don't see how you could do this
to your own child
just a devastating development yesterday
in the case of amari nicholson
the body of the little two-year-old boy
was found exactly one week
after he disappeared metro police found
the boy's body yesterday alex
it was behind a wall at the siegel
suites near paradise and twain
that is right next to the emerald suites
the last place amari was seen
last week police say the little boy was
murdered by his mother's
boyfriend terrell rhodes he was watching
amari while the mother was out of town
investigators say rhodes confessed to
hitting amari numerous times
which caused his death then hit his body
rhodes was arrested earlier this week
and now faces a murder charge
he appeared in court for the first time
yesterday morning he is currently being
held without bail
and is due back in court on monday now
alex our i-team has learned there may
have been warning signs amari was in
danger
sources telling the i-team within the
past year there was at least one report
made to child protective services
alleging abuse
the agency looked into the allegation
however they closed the case
and didn't take any further action it's
such a devastating story it's really
impacted the community this huge group
of people gathered at a vigil yesterday
afternoon
near paradise and twain close family
friends remembered amari as a beautiful
boy
and a special soul we will continue to
follow the latest
and that court appearance as well coming
up